[Musique]
c'est déjà mieux
moi c'est déjà mieux ça c'est plus
mignon sur youssef ce que ça donne ça un
fils en gueule oxo good tu t'imagines je
dirais moi aussi j'aime acheter un lave
vaisselle hayden et je vais trop rose
avec un cas vraiment que la vaisselle
etc mais vois pas quoi
[Musique]
il y en a certains qui m'ont demandé si
vraiment c'était plus possible des
calendriers du coup on en a repris mais
quelques-uns voilà donc ça se joue là
qu'ils sont en train de partir je vous
remets alors tu vas choisit quoi pour le
prime une sélection de pièces assez
original comme tu le joueur malien banon
comme d'hab attend ça fait bientôt deux
mois que tu étais un accident on te
remettre plus ça avance plus les cartes
l'accord dont bien sûr la wii
[Applaudissements]
et leïla leïla leïla leïla est malade
d'amour qui me rappelle de quoi bisness
que la télévision sous l'escalier des
chiites ouais bon je prends à l'image
ici ce soir et je cite fera pas
quelqu'un 3 2 1
yeah mettez là ça c'est mon chéri je
laime il va cartonner ce soir je serai
même tarbes asie mon pote alé lô
alibaba ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
georges
[Musique]
enregistrement de drôlement bête sur
france klm voilà donc vous voyez du coup
ça veut dire que j'ai perdu mais pas là
cette fois ci les costumes sont très
très mignon donc c'est très bien
tu aimais avec le muc touche pas aux
passants gaz de palais c'est un salut
l'ambiance y'a pas toi je laisse mon
régime jamais chaulage la cop10 par des
conducteurs peut-être peut-être un seul
à qui est ce qu'on l'a déjà fait
disparaître
[Musique]
l'ancien des bears au coeur d'une région
pour maintenance et la pause dej ya des
community petites loges et mon souper
avec tu es totalement raccord avec i2g
qui a déjà prédit ça va mieux par
exemple au tour de magie faits
dégueulasses aussi jeune et bel acte
barbare qui demain soir on adore
[Musique]